The 1970s gave us Jay Appleton, a geographer with a knack for turning human instinct into
architectural rules. He called it Prospect Refuge Theory, the idea that we're wired to crave two
things, the ability to see far and the ability to hide. It's an old trick, really. Back when we
were dodging lions on the savannah, a good vantage point meant survival. A safe corner meant sanity.
But what if we flipped it? What if we designed our lives to make those instincts work against us?
That's the art of spatial displacement, turning your home into a psychological pressure cooker.
Not just any space, but one that actively undermines your brain's hardwired comforts.
Because misery isn't just about what you do, it's about where you do it.
Take ceilings, for instance. Most people want them high, airy, expansive, the kind that make
you feel like you could think big. But you? You want them low, pressing down, not just on your head,
but on your thoughts. Low ceilings don't just trap you physically, they trap you intellectually.
They force your mind into a box where every idea has to squeeze through the same narrow door.
Now, let's talk about the claustrophobic anchor. Most people pick a chair with their back to the wall,
safe, predictable. But you? You sit with your back to the door. Not because it's clever. Because it's
cruel. Your brain doesn't know the difference between a line at the entrance and a draft.
Every time you glance over your shoulder, your amygdala gets a little jolt, predator alert.
And suddenly, deep work becomes impossible. You're not just distracted. You're hunted. By your own
furniture. And windows? Oh, windows are a dangerous thing. During the day, you keep them shrouded blinds,
drawn, light-blocked, no prospect, no escape. Your brain craves the horizon, but you give it a blank
wall instead. Then, at night, you flip the script, blinds up, exposed, like a bug under a microscope.
The world outside watches. Or maybe it doesn't. But your mind doesn't know that. It feels watched.
And that's the point. Then, there's the furniture labyrinth. Every right-angle turn, every sharp corner,
every time your shin catches on a misplaced ottoman that's not an accident. That's design.
You want movement to be a chore. A series of small, irritating collisions. Because misery isn't just
about stillness. It's about the friction of existing. And surfaces? Oh, surfaces are for visual
static. Piles of mail that never get opened. Glasses half full of something that's been forgotten.
Cables snaking like the roots of a dying plant. Your brain can't help but process it. All every loose
thread. Every half-hidden object. It's like trying to meditate in a hurricane. The storm doesn't have to
be loud. It just has to never stop. The goal? To turn your home into a cage. Not a gilded one. Not a cozy one.
A cage where every wall is a reminder that you're trapped. And every view was a lie. You'll never be
safe here. Not really. Because safety isn't about space. It's about control. And in this architecture,
you have none. The bathroom stall is the only place that offers refuge. A tiny, enclosed box where the
door can lock out the world. But even there, you're not free. No prospect. No escape. Just the echo
of your own breath against the tile. Give a man a view, and he dreams. Give a man a wall, and he ruminates.
Be the man with the wall. Because in the end, misery isn't about what you see. It's about what what you can't.
Concentration